the book language of creation cosmic
symbolism in Genesis written by my
brother Matt seer is finally out and so
I have met you with me and we will be
talking about his book about the
structures the impetus for writing it
and also talking about a whole bunch of
other things like consciousness and how
it relates to religion
[Music]
this is Jonathan Petro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Applause]
hello everybody um I've been telling you
for weeks we've been waiting for matches
book to come out I've been telling you
that it's on the verge of coming and
here it is it's finally out so Mateusz
book is available you can find it on
Amazon and because of that I've also
been waiting and hoping that Metz who's
going to come back on this channel so
that we can talk and so he's here with
me and I'm good we're gonna talk about
his book so I'm pretty excited I have
been going over the for the final copies
and the final edits of the book and
every time I read it you know that
everything kind of builds up and and and
when you get I always tell people when
you get to about page 100 you kind of
start having seizures because everything
starts to connect together and it's it's
pretty it's it's it's pretty amazing so
Matt you thanks for for for joining me
um I'm gonna start with a basic question
maybe you can tell people what it is
that prompted you to write this what
were you trying to accomplish what was
what was the the motivation for for this
book on on a commentary on the Bible
well I'd say my my first motivation is
an interest in symbolism and in the
Bible of course but then in looking for
answers to certain questions I realized
that nobody out there was talking about
symbolism in the way I was looking for
at least so I went I took certain
classes at a university level in the
Department of Religious Studies and I
quickly realized that it was feminism it
was class about feminism hook it's not
about religion
it wasn't about symbolism it was about
feminism and Marxism so so that pretty
much led me to pretty much decide you
right there that one day I was going to
try to write something myself because
nobody nobody else was doing it so um so
basically what I realized in general is
that in academia when they talk about
the Bible and when they talk about
subjects that are related to symbolism
what they do is always the same thing
they use their own
categories of interpretation so they use
their own lens to look at the text look
the stories and they analyze it
according to their own ideology in their
own lens so basically they're using well
it's all grounded in materialism so
that's right there that that pretty much
announced any possibility of
understanding real symbolism because
real symbolism is is not a materialistic
so if you look at it through
materialistic lens you might get some
glimpses of what it means you might get
some insights but you're always gonna be
in a situation where things that are
actually simple will appear extremely
complex okay because when you look at
the at something with the wrong lens
that's usually what happens you can you
can look at something that's extremely
simple if you if you look at the world
with certain categories and then if you
look at it with the wrong categories you
might get an understanding of it but it
will be extremely complex and it will
look I don't know artificial maybe the
way is the way they say whereas if you
look at it with the right lens in a look
absolutely natural and it looks as if
it's almost self-evident like how could
I miss that that's what happens when you
when you change your perspective when
you use the right lens to look at the
Bible all of a sudden things become kind
of obvious you can almost predict what's
gonna happen in a story when you have
the correct lens you see what's
happening you know where its leading
look at it with the right kind of like
if you understand science and you and
you look at a projectile you can you can
figure out what's gonna happen in
advance you don't need to see it you
know it's gonna fall you can kind of
guess the distance you can even
calculate it if you did you have the
right information but so it's kind of
the same thing here if you look at the
world with the lens of symbolism
you can predict certain things and in
the Bible but not just in the Bible in
the real world too if you start looking
at the world with this particular lens
you can make sense of a lot of what's
going on in particularly with a lot of
what's going on right now what's going
on politics love what's going on at the
social level and makes a lot
cents if you look at it with the proper
lens it's almost um I don't know how to
say it's almost like it has to happen
like what's happening right now even
though it looks completely insane if you
look at it with a proper lens it's
almost like okay this is has to happen
it's gonna happen and then after that
there's gonna be something else so it's
not it becomes less of a big deal
actually you get it correctly I think
yeah I think that that's what really
struck me in in reading the book is that
you know I have you know we both of us
we kind of have these these intuitions
or patterns and I have certain patterns
that I work with and everything but
what's amazing is that you really go
into the text and you pull out what is
really a such a simple pattern I mean
it's very basic you know you it's a
geometric like it's very it's very basic
and then you it's like it's almost like
you're reading it's almost mathematical
right it's so precise and and it's so
simple it's almost I always even when
I'm reading what I was reading the book
I thought I hope people in it's almost
too simple for people who were looking
for something you know flighty and and
complicated it's like you have to enter
into that simplicity and then once you
see it then then after that through the
whole book you just keep showing over
and over here it is here it is this is
how it's played itself out here and here
and year and yeah it's it's it's quite
astounding so so maybe you can tell us a
little bit about the the basic I would
say like the basic structure let's say
because I know a lot of it has to do
with the relationship between space and
time so maybe you can give us a just a
little glimpse of what the basic pattern
is that you're that you that you've that
you kind of entered into when you were
reading the text okay well basically
well I have a I have a background in
mathematics and that's kind of how I
looked at it
that's not people usually do when they
read the Bible they don't necessarily
really like that but I began having
pretty deep insights in
the stories of the Bible when I started
analyzing it like a mathematician okay
so basically I was just trying to figure
out what are the fundamental categories
of this quality so obviously when I
started reading Bible the first thing in
the beginning God created heaven in
earth so to me when you look at it with
some kind of a mathematical lens you say
okay that those are the first axiom okay
so you have God we have heaven we have
Hertz so those are the axioms if I
derive everything from that then I've
got a sound I've got a sound theory
theory but I've got a sound system so
that's that's the basic framework of the
Bible but I also think it's the basic
framework of every traditional cosmology
there there ever was well any all the
cosmologies I've encountered
they've always been based on this simple
structure heaven earth and then there is
the union of heaven and earth and that
it's like the cosmos happens there okay
so it's like the tuple of manifestation
is heaven in it and then there is a
third element which is called man in the
Bible or atom and that is like a
consciousness that mediates between
heaven and earth and that's also
something I've encountered in in in
almost every other tradition it's not
always called with the same names but
it's you can tell that it's basically
the same pattern so so that's the first
pattern okay I've understood that for a
very long time okay because it's so it's
obvious in the Bible like I said it
starts with that starts like then but
that doesn't necessarily mean that it's
easy to figure out what all the
implications are okay so it's like
mathematics you can I could tell I could
state the axioms of the basic systems of
arithmetic right now and that doesn't
mean people can figure out what are the
implications that's time to figure out
what the implications are when you have
principles because a basic principle is
something that contains huge amounts of
implications but if they're it's in a
simple simple form so the book you talk
about how
we often think that something that
things are too complicated to understand
but then you know you mentioned that
sometimes things are actually too simple
to understand
yeah there's simplicity you know you
could miss what it's actually about
because it just seems so it's it's too
contained in a seed let's say yeah
exactly
that's something not necessarily
everybody has to deal with if you study
science and mathematics you might be a
little more used to that because if you
have a simple scientific formula like a
a simple equation that describes certain
forces that's an extremely simple
concept but then when you usually in
practice when you use it to interpret
you as a lens okay so if you have as a
formula use it as a lens to interpret
reality you're not trying to understand
the formula you're trying to understand
reality with the form you're losing in
as glasses so yeah I'm putting on the
some scientific theory and looking at
the world and now I'm seeing all the
implications of that theory and I'm
seeing also if it matches with reality
matches with my idea so basically that's
the way I approach the Bible so
sometimes the concepts are extremely
simple and like you said you have to not
be turned off by that at the beginning
because the beginning well this is
something I encounter often somebody
asked me for example what is it what
does the I just giving example here what
is the tree mean for example I usually
don't know what to say because the tree
is a fundamental pattern in this in this
worldview
so how am I gonna explain it it's it's
it's the other way around
you don't give examples examples
examples yeah come back to the
fundamental notion of of the tree yeah
you don't explain what the tree is you
use the tree as a pattern of
interpretation it's not the same thing
it's like flipping a river because if
I'm going to describe what it is I'm
gonna have to use other categories to
describe what it is and which category
is am I going to use the categories of
materialism well that's what symbolism
do yeah they use the categories of
materialism and then they try to
interpret
cymbals with those categories and the
result is is sometimes interesting but
yeah it misses a lot of the obvious
meanings that that if you just change
your your goggles thing you'll see the
right the right stuff so yeah okay so
heaven and earth that's the most basic
categories that has a lot of implication
I use those categories throughout the
book I everything I say in the book
derives directly from that that pattern
okay and then there is another important
structure is time and space yeah okay so
I talked about time and space but it's
not the time and space that that we can
find in physics okay it's it's like an
archaic concept of time and space and if
I define them very simply I define them
out of heaven and earth actually I say
so space this is gonna be an example of
a very simple definition that looks like
it doesn't really mean anything
but so space is when heaven and earth
agree that's like the definition of what
I call space and time is when they don't
immediately agree okay so it's you could
call it truth and true and false yeah
because that's what it is true means
heaven meets or agrees with earth okay
it means the meaning of something
matches the fact right exactly that's an
easy way for input this year yeah the
identity of something matches the fact
of the thing so if you have if you're a
scientist and you have a theory that's
the heaven and then you do some
experiments you're trying to see if
heaven in Earth's match yeah we're
trying to see if your theory is true to
the fact many wise person if the fact is
true to the theory so it's the
definition of truth so in my book I call
that space okay um
and I go I talk a lot about it it's not
just an anecdote and and then there's
the other side is when it doesn't match
so that's when you have an idea and the
facts the facts of reality are not
fitting with your idea that doesn't
necessarily mean always that the ideas
fall
or that the fact is wrong it could be
yeah just doesn't fit any factors yeah
currently doesn't fit sometimes it can
fit with some work sometimes it can fit
if you get a little bit clear
understanding but anyway the idea is
true and false that's what I go yeah
spacing time yeah I have I have a I have
this image and is I tried to find one of
the most basic examples that to help
people understand how immediate this is
is is imagine you're you're you're uh
you're a child like you're you're a
growing child and then you have a shirt
and you wear this shirt right so you
wear this shirt the shirt is space it
fits you and you're wearing it and then
at some point you know the child grows
grows grows now the shirt it doesn't fit
and so now there's there's a there's a
there's a disjunct right between the the
the reality of the child and his face
his clothing that he wears and so the
only solution to that is change change
you have to change something you have to
change that's why I use an example to
explain why I call this change time is
change when things don't fit they have
to change and they do things you you
explain really that's important is that
we have we think that change just means
things developing let's say but you
really differentiate change which would
be let's say the the change of the of
the of the child becoming a man right
and the change of changing the clothing
that goes on the child one is is is
something manifesting itself in its own
identity and the other is is actually
you have to transform into something
else I get actually transformed into
other you have to adjust reality to fit
an identity and so it's not it's it's
two different we tend to think those two
are changed but you really try to to to
separate those two because because if
you if you think that they're the same
then you you end up in a confusing and
confusing place yeah well that's yeah
there's a chapter in my book about
exactly that and maybe one or two and
that's actually pretty important because
it's related to materialism yeah if
you're not a materialist things have an
identity and they have a body concrete
reality in a nice ideal reality and then
when when change means something happens
where this doesn't fit anymore but if
you're a materialist change doesn't mean
that because there's no like things
don't have an essence so it's not even
about symbolism per se even if you think
in terms of Aristotle or in terms of
philosophy before materialism the
concept of change is the same as the one
I'm describing here it's the idea of
transformation so if you talk about
transformation you have to you have to
acknowledge that there is a form there's
the concept of form somewhere so as soon
as you you have the concert perform you
have it because of transformation or not
transformation so something can become
bigger and bigger without transforming
yeah so that's the idea a shape can
remain true to itself even if it grows
in size if it doesn't it stays the same
in a sense and here let's say you change
a square into a circle that's a
transformation if you make a square
bigger it's not as transformation it's
not change that's just an it a way to
distinguish the the concepts here okay
so basically my book I talk about like I
said time and space which has not not
very much anything to do with our
current notions of time and space and
one of the important concepts is is the
fact that the time is cyclical that is
extremely important it's one of the
things that go into in my book a lot
because it has a lot of implications we
are absolutely not used to thinking in
terms of this cyclical pattern we're
just not used to doing it so I try to
give some examples in my book of what it
means of how this pattern manifests the
cycle um because it's something we're
not used to I don't exactly know why
it's a strange thing actually because we
live in cycles all the time I mean we
days we have weeks we have years like
our entire life is is filled with cycles
it's funny that people tend to think of
time just just as a linear kind of
succession of moments let's say which I
mean that obviously that's not how we
experience it and people often say
people often say things like oh Easter
traditions have cyclical time in western
Susan's have linear mind I think that's
just wrong I draw I think that's just an
example of I don't know how to say this
but it's it's just an example of how
academia try it is trying to kind of
subvert the tradition of Christianity
and by any means possible in one of
those ways is to find other traditions
and then use that to show that this one
is lacking in some way or that's
actually one of the things that turned
me off for me from the University level
studies about the Bible's most of it is
subversion yeah to be honest it's all
about we're gonna suffer Christianity or
maybe maybe even Judaism traditional
religion basically we're gonna subvert
it we're gonna replace it with yeah but
they can use they can use and that's why
you hear use other religions as a weapon
basically in order to destroy
Christianity it's not like to actually
care about about you'll say northern
paganism but they care about it to the
extent that they can say we'll look Odin
hung from a tree and therefore
Christianity is just baloney because
here are other traditions where someone
hangs from a tree it's like they don't
they just use it as a weapon to bludgeon
Christianity yes actually this is one of
the read that one of the the reasons why
I wanted to write my book was to get rid
of some of those argumentation because
they're kind of childish for example
someone sees something in some other
foreign religion and then they see the
same pattern in Christianity and then
they say oh this one must come from that
one or this one
a copy of that one to me that means you
don't understand the pattern
you don't understand the how fundamental
it is how obvious it is and so to you
it's just a strange thing so how did it
get from I don't know how didn't get
from Africa back to America or and then
you have to find some weird causality
because I'm very very sick no I think
that this these these symbols are
strange they don't make sense so if you
see them it in one place and then you
see them in another you have to explain
them through some kind of mechanical
causality but if you understand the
meaning of it you don't have to do that
it's obvious like the pattern of reality
so of course it's going that it's going
to it's going to manifest itself
symbolism is going to happen you know it
you just because that's the the basic
structure of the world yeah because it
describes exactly it describes a reality
it's not because this is also one of the
ways that was used to subvert acting as
if it was completely arbitrary yeah so
the story is the symbols they're
arbitrary you know they were just made
up by some person usually they could be
any kind of a Marxist way they were they
went Valley for power control - I don't
even know I don't even know what to say
you can always analyze anything in that
lens anyway so it's not just religion if
you want anything anybody says you can
analyze it with the lens of power and
you can criticize it like that so it's
not it it's not even a valid criticism
might be might be so anyway when you
start understanding the patterns you see
them in different places you see them in
the Bible you also see them in different
traditions I'm not I'm not trying to say
that all traditions are the same or
anything like that but they had a common
basic framework of understanding reality
and it's actually pretty amazing how how
universal it was I mean you can you look
at Native American traditions and you
see the exact same fundamental patterns
you know see heaven use the earth you
see the tree you see the hoop you see
all these patterns it's exactly the same
patterns
okay so that means it doesn't mean
though there was necessarily transfer of
knowledge from one to the other or
possible but it means that they're just
describing the reality it just happens
to be not the same exact reality as the
physicist is trying to describe
but in the end what's and what's
interesting in your book and it's
something that that's been kind of
floating around and in different
discussions online in my discussion with
John Peterson and Brett Weinstein and
everything is that is that in your book
you you you end up containing science
within your symbolic framework because
you talk about this problem of theory in
fact right so maybe you can talk about
that because I think that's something
that enjoyed that will interest people
oh yeah this is also another reason the
idea of reconciling science and religion
is obviously very important to me as I
think it is for a lot of people because
it's it's like a nine a m-- because it's
like our past doesn't fit with our our
present and future yeah and if there's
something unsettling about that I don't
want to think that all of our ancestors
were a bunch of idiots I don't want to
think like that
okay so I'm be be the idea that I want
to reconcile these two universes it's
just something that's in me I don't even
know where it comes from
it bothers me just I don't want to
separate from the past I want to join
things together so the idea of
reconciling science and tradition or
religion has been always in my head
since I was a teenager and I got
interested in evolutionary theory
at first it was to debate it or confront
it as a Christian and then after a while
at one point I said okay I'm gonna read
Darwin's book I'm just gonna read it I'm
gonna stop just assuming it's wrong and
I'm gonna read it so I read it and I
thought it was really interesting and I
saw in no way how that contradicted my
ideas about God or anything like that so
Camille a data had no contradiction I
first did but then slowly I started to
see that I had a a weird glimpse at at
one point I could say maybe a kind of a
spiritual experience where I was trying
to reconcile these these worldviews so
let's say evolution and creation okay
and then I had this weird glimpse where
I saw how if you include the theory of
science in the evolutionary process then
everything changes exactly almost
becomes like a religious worldview okay
and this is one of the reasons why we're
interested in Jordan Peterson first of
all you're the one who first talk to me
about Jordan Peterson but then I became
really interested when he started
talking in these terms because that can
occur in size with some of the glimpses
I had when I was trying to reconcile
creation and well now I wouldn't even
use the word creationism anymore you see
creation and what modern scientific
knowledge I had this glimpse where I saw
that the whole problem is the scientific
theory is not included in the worldview
of the scientist so the scientist is not
putting his own theory
it's like he's separating his theory
from his from the world it's like more
completely it's as if his theory doesn't
actually exist in the world like it's
it's he doesn't think about like he
doesn't even it says it's a blind spot
is what it is yeah at the same time I
understand this is where the power of
materialism comes from it's like I don't
even know how to say it's like a denial
of spiritualities the theory that the
scientist has is part of the spiritual
realm yeah
I'm careful when I use these terms
because I know people will interpret it
you know it's not material yeah your
theory about the world is not material
hey so no matter how you look at it it's
not material so because of that they
they act like the theory itself is not
part of the universe and has no
influence on the universe but it
obviously does I mean if you're a
scientist and you discover something
that explains reality and then reality
changes it's not it's not a weird
metaphor or some weird new agey thing
you're a scientist you have a theory you
experiment you show that it works and
then you transform the world you change
the world with your understanding of the
world so tell me again
how your theory is not in your model
dealers so they missing their because
when you understand in the world the
world you influence the world you don't
even have to look at it at a quantum
level or anything like that
you can look at a normal level the
scientist understands he makes the
connection with reality
then he gains power in the world yeah
not me sure that in particular
individual but humanity using that
knowledge gained power controlled in
control over the world and understanding
of the world so why had why is it your
theory part of one of the forces that's
in the world why isn't it part of the
your model so anyway so that was the
glimpse that I had at that moment and it
kind of blew my it in my mind I don't
know how to say and it took me maybe 20
years to deal with that yeah it's how to
deal with that idea is that just an idea
including the theory in the in the model
yeah so I guess my book is kind of maybe
the culmination of that it a took a lot
of twists and turns and finally it's not
the subject per se of the book but it
permeates the book would say yeah my
understanding or my questioning about
that problem is what led me to
understand the traditional cosmology in
a certain way and in the end what I see
is that the traditional cosmology is
that what I'm describing it's a universe
in which the scientists has included his
theory in the in the universe and has
included his model of the universe in
the universe and even when I just say
that you can see that that is how
traditional knowledge works because if
you look at ancient patterns it's always
you have a cosmos and then you have a
mini cosmos and then you have another
meaning it's like a like a fractal yes
putting a mirror in front of another
mirror it's exactly what happens
knowledge works like this is really I
think this is really for the book this
is really to me one of the glorious
aspects of your book is that you know we
probably talk about let's say microcosms
you know it mean people have been
talking about the notion
you know that man is a microcosm for you
know for centuries since Plato or
whatever but but but would you are able
to do in your book it which is amazing
is you actually show it you you would
actually creature it even in diagrams
like you create these these diagrams
that are that are fractal that move into
each other and then you do it with the
story then you kind of show how he with
you know within a story you know the
different aspects of the story are many
versions of the whole story and it's I
mean that is just to me that's a it's a
totally false like we say like you're
really able to to show it because it's
easy to talk about it we kind of we have
an intuition that that's how the world
works sometimes but but you're able to
really kind of show it in uh in terms of
out but I'll do is I'll edit I'll put
some diagrams like just to show people
at least they'll see the diagrams on the
video of how you're able to kind of
embed these these parts into each other
yeah that's something I want to mention
with regard to my book one of the ways
that I dealt with the problem of that I
was describing at the beginning of our
discussion um where the idea that when
people try to understand symbolism or
interpret the Bible or a traditional
story they're using the lens of science
they're using the lens of different
disciplines academic disciplines that
are all grounded in materialism because
that's the world we're in right now so
um so one of the ways I try to not to
help the reader look through the
different lens is by using images
diagrams because so what happens I'm not
a neuropsychologist or anything like
that
but there's a part of our mind that it
when it uses visual images it doesn't
interpret them the same way as language
so um I found that it was possible to
get the person to look through the lens
of certain categories by using pictures
instead of words because when you use
word the person interprets the language
with with their own categories so if I
use a certain word
so for example this is
something I talk about in my book if I
say the word heaven well most people
will interpret it with a current lens
and they live that they'll say I'm
talking about the sky right and the
atmosphere so if I use the word heaven I
have to be very careful to remind the
reader that I'm not talking about the
atmosphere right oh but the problem it's
OK for a couple of terms like that but
when all the words don't at some point
every single word that you're using it
has to be reinterpreted it becomes a
little bit painful right it's like every
word I have to say when I say this
actually means this I don't mean what
you think and when I say this I mean
this it would be simple so what I did
was I use pictures a lot of them there's
a lot of images in my book and it's
always the same pattern I really repeat
repeat the purpose of that is for the
reader to kind of get this imprinted in
their in their brain the basic
fundamental patterns of symbolism so you
have the hierarchy you have the cycle
you have the idea of heaven and earth
write it like a duality of heaven and
earth so that pattern is repeated I
don't know how many times like maybe
over a hundred the reason is is because
I want that diagram that patron kept ya
imprinted in your mind so that you don't
think about it anymore and you just
slowly start to look like glasses you
don't know you're wearing your glasses
you're looking through them you're not
looking at them you're looking through
them so if I repeat the same pattern the
patterns kind of becomes your your
glasses right your lens so that's the
reason why you've so many so many
diagrams so basically I use the same
patterns and I use them to interpret
different parts of the Bible stories the
story of Cain and Abel the story of Noah
the story of the fall a dominions a
serpent at the tree and all that so I
reuse always the same patterns in every
single story to interpret so basically
they did is that they're all based on on
simple definitions except we're we're so
not used to thinking of that that I
couldn't just give the definition and
then talk about it as if it was acquired
because it takes a little bit of
to intuitively acquire this way of
thinking so there you go that's why you
have so many images that but that's also
why I'm telling
I tell people like make it to like paid
100 right at the beginning you're
building like it's a minute it's been
more of an effort yet you're building
you're building and then once you reach
when you reach some of the examples that
you give I say page 100 I'm not even
sure if that's the that the right place
maybe even a bit before and then all of
a sudden things start to click like you
you I could I you know and it's funny
because you and I we were your probably
the person who think the most like me
let's say in the world I would say but
even though despite that as I was
reading your text it was there was
really a magical aspect to it like it
was really she I could feel it changing
some of my perception like I could feel
it transforming some of my of the way
that I view the world and and and kind
of fusing choosing things together in my
mind and so I think it's it's definitely
it's evidently um yeah it definitely has
something magical about it like it's a I
think that people reading this book it's
if you read it honestly it'll be
difficult to reach the end without being
changed in terms of your frame of you
like in terms of the way you see the
universe yeah and of course the idea
always is not to become insane or
anything that maybe I should give that
warning because I see it happens when
you change your your lens you take your
lens you can go insane because what
happens and then you try to communicate
those ideas to people around you and
then they have no clue what you're
talking about
and they look at you like you're insane
so that's probably one of the key
factors in becoming insane is when you
start saying things and people around
you're acting like you're you're saying
gibberish so just fair warning don't go
insane again fair warning don't go
insane while reading my book do you
think in those terms exactly that's
hilarious
oh man and I think that one of the
things that one of the things that is is
really going to be surprising to people
that you really you really don't shy
from any subject like you you you talk
about time and space and about society
and about cycles of time but then you
talk about human beings you talk about
sexuality about taboos about you know
all the weird stuff a lot of the weird
stuff in the Bible that you know about
Giants and fallen angels and all this
stuff in the Bible that is so weird
people they look at it and they just
think it's absolute insanity but you you
kind of bring it all together and I
think that that's something that people
are really going to are really going
really going to open their eyes like
it's the last part of the book
especially I think it's really going to
surprise people in terms of how not only
talking about all that weird stuff but
talking about it in a way that helps is
that we're what's happening now again
it's it's showing us exactly where we
are now what is the all this weird stuff
that's happening exactly all the
inversions all the upside down world
it's like you make total sense of that
especially in the last part of the book
where you you start talking about those
subject so I think it's going to be yeah
that's all I'm really I'm really you
know what I'm also excited is to to to
to start to see people talk about it and
start to see people discuss it on on on
social media so it'll be interesting to
see people kind of bring things up and
and see how it how it morphs into
different things yeah I'm curious to see
also what the reaction will be because I
have no idea if it will fly or not I
mean I've been doing this for about four
years so I've completely immersed myself
in this way of thinking so to me these
things have become absolutely obvious
yeah so I don't first comments like on
the first day that it was out it was so
funny because I didn't even know that it
was out because I think it was kind of
you put it up on on WizIQ on Kindle
right yeah and I didn't even know he was
out and someone else on Twitter said
I've been reading it all day that's not
like to book it out instead I've been
reading it all day and it's exactly
everything I was hoping for then I got
another comment someone telling me he's
saying that yeah their mind was
constantly being blown and so every
comment obviously every comment that
I've gotten has been more than just oh
it's good it's been like okay this is
really changing really changing the way
I view the world so I think that at
least for people who are who cool read
it honestly it's going to it's going to
have the effect that we're hoping it's
gonna have yeah one of the things I want
to say is that I'm not trying neither to
convince anyone of anything I'm just
describing something that I understood
I'm not trying to convince anyone this
is also why I don't shy away from
subjects because I'm not trying to I'm
not even trying to reconcile the ideas
that are in the Bible with our current
way of understanding I'm not even trying
to do that I'm just trying to describe
my understanding of these stories and
sometimes it gets a little weird but the
weirdness is not it's not absurd it
makes it's a weirdness that makes sense
it's only a question of okay we don't
see the word like that right now or we
don't say it like that anymore maybe in
the past they did at least it helps us
to reconcile the past a little bit
instead of thinking that our ancestors
were a bunch of fools you can at least
say okay they they weren't concerned
with the same things as we are we're
interested in technical knowledge we've
advanced really really far in technical
knowledge and we and we have brilliant
insights into that but we've also lost
certain a certain kind of understanding
that our ancestors obviously had and
yeah it's it's it's important to not
make light of the fact that our
worldview is completely different from
that of the best there's something
eerily wrong about that we have to
figure out some ways to bring them
together like I said I don't try to do
that in my book what I try to do in my
book in terms of science in terms of the
relationship between tradition and
science is just to give a way out to to
this like the spiritual understanding of
the world just get away from out from
under the foot of science okay because
science has been crushing crushing down
on traditional knowledge for a long time
and I'm not complaining or anything like
that I love science I've always loved
science I'm just noticing that
religionists is taking less and less
space the
problem with that is it will be replaced
by something else okay and that thing is
gonna be weird yeah okay if you don't if
we don't understand what's happening
that something very strange is gonna
happen it's happening now weird stuff is
happening is because no but it's already
happened it happened we had a cycle of
it in the 20th century I mean communism
and Nazism was exactly that was exactly
a space in which boy the materialist
worldview you know that something was
filling filling up the void of
spirituality in in in the world and so
we kind of we I mean we killed 100
million people now we're taking our
breath but it's we haven't dealt with
anything it's like we're basically just
taking our breath from those hundred
million deaths in the 20th century and
if people think it's not coming back and
unless we can unless unless we can
reconcile these things it's going to
come back there's no and like you said
it's already happening like we look
around I always tell people like we are
sitting we are standing in via our
Germany right now like you know create
by my Germany times 100 is where we are
and so what comes after that you know
it's not pretty
no yes so we have to figure out what
what happened because traditional
knowledge is is not it's not rat it's
not the same as experimental or rational
knowledge and when I say that I'm not
saying that it's irrational because it's
not but it's a kind of knowledge that's
been passed down it's it's passed the
test of time okay that's not nothing
that's a big deal it means it works
that's what it means it means there's
something in it that fits with reality
now it doesn't necessarily fit with our
scientific understanding of reality but
maybe it fits with some aspects of
reality that we're not aware of so we
should never just throw away ancient
knowledge like that as if it was nothing
yeah something that's been around for
thousands of years might contain some
information that you don't know as a
modern person yeah and especially as we
move and this is something that we've
talked about and it's something that's
kind of been popping up more and more
online and any different discussion as
we move towards these these movements in
cognitive science and this movement
towards trying to understand
and human consciousness we are we're
seeing little glimpses of a connection
where as we talk about cognitive science
it there is this notion that you you
then you once again you have to fit
cognition in the world like cognition
has to be a a phenomena in the world it
has to be part of the universe are our
thoughts have to be part of the universe
are our you know our understanding has
to be part of the universe and when that
happens all of a sudden some of the
structures we are seeing some of the
structures that you talk about in your
book popping up even in scientific
discourse so that's really fascinating
yeah well yeah we were talking about
before we started recording the you sent
me a link to a yes Sam herons of all
people he shared on Twitter this
discussion with Hoffman I think his name
is which I think it's often a I'll put a
link in the description a podcast where
he talks about the science of cognition
John Hoffman John Hoffman and how
basically he positing a theory that
consciousness is a constitutive element
of the universe which I mean it's like
that's what we're saying you know we're
try this what were that's where we're
going yeah you people so there there's
like bridges being created right now I
would say between traditional knowledge
and scientific technical knowledge and I
think it's great I don't know where it's
good exactly how it's gonna happen but
it's clearly there's things are
happening things are coming together so
I don't bully my book will help a little
bit in some aspect of that maybe to
understand religion or this perspective
in its own in its own way not in the way
not interpreting it through a different
lens interpret trying to adopt that
world you see the world through that
worldview instead of just analyzing it
from a different perspective and looking
at it because there's always a little
bit of a cynical undertone to that when
you look at religion with a lens that
it's a matter what lens you use if you
use sociology or anything like that it's
like
even theirs I was a little bit of an
undertone of cynicism it's normal
because part of you has to look at it
like it's not true or like it say
something wrong with it because it
doesn't quite fit your categories so you
have to like deal with what doesn't fit
in a way that's kind of a little bit
cynical so it's like I'm gonna accept
this part of it but this part of it it's
just that's just we're not gonna go back
to that or we're not gonna even try to
understand it because that's just
nonsense or it's just the word yeah see
that's that's the thing I mean if you're
a scientist and you look at a phenomenon
and then you see an anomaly not supposed
to say oh I'm gonna I'll you know look
at that it's stupid no you're supposed
to say whoa maybe my theory is it
doesn't account for that anomaly I have
to change my theory to account for that
anomaly because saying that an anomaly
just isn't important it if that's fine
for a while but then you know what
happens the science is dealt with our
problem how many times you can put the
anomaly under the rug for a while and it
always comes back to take you down in
the end so it's the same thing when
studying traditional knowledge the
anomalies are there to tell you hey
there's something you don't understand
not not the other way around
so that's my that's my perspective honey
all right guys so so view the book is
out it's on Amazon you can you can find
it at your different do whatever country
you're in go to Amazon put Monsieur
Poirot in the search or the the language
of creation and and buy the book leave a
review as well where do we're trying to
push it now and you know hopefully we
can we can attract a little bit of
attention to it and this is the place so
we're going to be talking about the book
once in a while on the on this channel
and I want to foster your discussion as
well we'll try to find spaces for all of
you guys to to discuss the book and talk
about the ideas and we'll try to find
ways to do that another thing is that
some people have been asking me how is
it that I can encourage material because
materia it's kind of he's not he doesn't
have an online presence you know he he
has a slightly more hermit personality
and so he's not online on social media
for sure so what we're going to do is
I'm going to put a link to my tears
patreon account he's gonna open a
patreon account and his paypal so if
people want to support what he's doing
financially then we'll have a way for
you to do that and so stay tuned and
hopefully mightor will also come back
because while he was finishing his book
he said no I don't want to make any
videos you know I just have to focus I
need to finish this thing but now it's
finished so I'm hoping that we'll see
more of him on my channel as well so I
don't know we'll see about that
I have to find ways to coax him to
continue to come on to the channel so
it's alright so people stay tuned and
thanks for thanks for watching all right
buh-bye
hey if you enjoyed this content in our
exploration of symbolism get involved I
love to read your comments in the
comment section below please go ahead
and share this on social media to all
your friends and also please consider
supporting us financially on patreon
you'll find the link to the patreon page
in the description below